dan has been challenging me with
searches so i thought i would challenge
him back and i'll give him something
that i think is fairly difficult to
figure out but he's the expert so he'll
put me to shame all right let's hear it
i want to know
whether
there is recycling whether if i'm a
citizen of
let's say
mumbai bombay okay i'm a citizen of
mumbai whether there is a recycling
program and and get you know information
on how i can get recycling to to happen
for my household or something all right
well i'm going to use my search engine
of choice here and go back to google all
right
i've got to click up here
and i would say
i do it very simply i start with
recycling program
mumbai
oops well i misspelled that but it the
spell correction kicked in that's
exactly what i want which is perfect
most of the time the spell correction is
exactly right so um the very first hit
here is from sf weekly a blog we know
about economists compares recycling
techniques of impoverished mumbai well
that could be um but down here look at
this uh waste recycling to begin at
mumbai schools oh so okay
and bbc news has an article on recycling
slum face uh that's a different kind of
thing
okay but this looks pretty promising uh
mumbai's recycling marvel so let's look
at this that's all right click through
there
because we wanna actually dig into the
article rather than just taking the word
of this abstract the little snippet we
saw there so here we see a little bit
article in india the government has
granted approval for plan vision mumbai
transform mumbai let's find recycling
okay
ravi uh not just a result apparently
it's a hub for a booming plastic
recycling sector right i think we've got
the answer here already yeah so yeah
so there you go um that was pretty good
there's a lot of indication in this
results page that there is recycling
there it looks like it's just beginning
yeah sort of starting it up yeah but we
click through
we're not clear what type of recycling
it might just be them sifting through
their waste and that they recycle but it
might not be the formal type of
recycling but yeah you're right we did
that was fast how formal do you want it
to be
how formal
if if like
their waste pickup schedule
ah okay you know here in mountain view
they come and pick it up every other
ever at least in my house they pick it
up every other uh tuesday morning i
would add something like schedule on to
that and see if we can't find that
uh now if there isn't one this is going
to be hard to prove yeah
non-existence of something is always
tough
uh particularly in uh just nascent sort
of recycling program in india but um
i don't see anything about
the schedules here i see lots of other
things like schedules for events maybe
if we do a pickup schedule although i
don't you know
there is enough english use in india
that i think that's right if it existed
they would probably print something or
and that that's that's a actually really
useful thing to know you're bringing a
lot of knowledge to this task suppose
we're checking for saudi arabia yeah i
wouldn't know if it would actually be in
english so we'd have to do something
different but let's try that pickup
collection schedule we have well new
york has recycling that's great i'm glad
you hear that they have a recycling
yeah
okay so uh this is uh
not giving us we're starting to get off
topic here right right right so in this
case we've added so many words that uh
it's it's the word mumbai is now is lost
in minority or it's being kind of
dominated by the other words so pick up
schedule recycling there's a lot of that
right right so in this case it's
probably not working out so well so we'd
have to keep digging into this um one
thing we could one trick we could try
would be to say site colon
dot
i n oh now you're doing the fancy stuff
now i'm doing a fantastic yeah so that's
saying site colon is kind of a
a a a key word to say
only sites that have an indian
this is india right so now all the
search results are only going to come
from indian websites so if it's going to
be there it's going to be in is that a
google specific thing or is that
generalizable across most search engines
it's mostly search engines so i know
bing has it as well okay yeah okay yeah
so this is actually great but you can
see the results are still not perfect
because we're getting movie theaters
we're getting uh although there's this
pollution control board yeah but all of
these pages now are dot i n at the end
so these are all indian web pages that's
right that's right okay so you can
actually see um there are articles here
from the government about improving
solid waste management yeah so this is a
great trick to know because it allows
you to basically restrict the the range
of answers coming back to just.ini or
india or
com or edu or whatever you want it to be
this gives me a good idea for your next
search task okay which is how do you
figure out what those extensions are so
i want to search for i want to figure
out the largest movie theater in
mongolia
okay how do i
well one how do i even know what the
extension is for mongolia sure mn or is
it
well i'll tell you those extensions yeah
are called top-level domains yep so what
i would do because i can't remember what
a mongolia is i would do a new google
search for
uh top level
domains
and you see right here top level domain
wikipedia yeah it if i click there
mongolia in the mix too
oh we could do that yeah uh so actually
let's try that
if i just add top over the name
we're in a hurry all right i'm sorry i
gotta type faster mongolia
there we go
uh oh there am i
okay i was right so now like now um well
let me ask you what's the top-level
domain for antarctica
for
antarctica and a a
good guess
keep going
a n a q
a q a
all the other a's have been used yeah so
mongolia now you wanted the largest
theater the largest theater largest
theater
so uh we're getting lots of theaters in
mongolia but uh wait a second oh look at
this
they had the largest selection of beer
in mongolia
yeah actually uh
this is not working real well this is uh
well here's oolong tour yeah eastern
mongolia
theaters i don't know you know it occurs
to me though that english is not the
predominant language among yeah good
point okay good so so what would be the
language of mongolia
um
i'm exposing my ignorance here okay it's
okay we have a search engine oh yeah
what is yeah what what language
of mongolia
it's called the mongolia see that's what
i would have guessed it's like the
capital of oklahoma uh mongolian
language
okay so uh
this is a is mongolian okay
that sort of makes sense but we can do
now let me show you another trick i can
say
search tools here i'm going to click on
that thing on the left
and then scroll down and say translated
form pages oh that's your this is yeah
this is now this is the good stuff okay
so this allows me to search in other
languages wow i didn't know this existed
yeah so this is fantastic now do we have
mongolian as language i don't know we'll
have to find out something for you guys
um we have uh chinese we've got all
these other languages we can do czech
but i don't see mongolia in the list
here it's probably not a big enough
language for us to actually have but
we've got a bunch of language but we
could then
we probably won't do it in this video
but then we could in hindi we could do a
search for recyclers exactly exactly
which would be fascinating so if we
wanted to go back to that we could redo
that test here but we don't have that's
fast the easy way to get to found a new
pastime but we could do something like
um
theaters
oolan
how do you spell oolong i think that
tour like that
there you go and we actually have a
suggestion
i'm willing to bet that's it yeah i
wonder if it's related to but let's just
probably migrate ancestors genghis it
could be very welcome
so uh look at this uh national drama
theater in holland tower batour national
academic so now let's add largest onto
that yeah
uh we still have the world's largest
travel site but we're starting to get uh
things to do with tour so if we click
through here
one of the biggest tourist attractions
is the state opera
so this is starting to give us hints
yeah and we can keep digging into this
and we do theater here i'm going to do
control f to find that
uh we have the state opera i'm willing
to bet that's it probably
probably
so 100 sure but that's pretty good
indicator i mean someone might not have
ever measured what the largest theater
in
that's right it is that's right might
not know and given that it's already
it's probably written in a mongolian
this is a great first approximation very
cool all right